right if we wanted to improve public
education with the first idea be to
defund teachers often improving a system
requires putting more funding into it
not less so I think you know the black
lives matter movement it has a way of
hitting on a thing that is a real issue
and then just precisely going to the
thing that won't solve it which is
really it seems almost like a feature
rather than a bug alright I'm here with
Coleman Hughes the great Coleman Hughes
how are you doing that doing pretty well
how are you good
let's get right into it all right okay
what do you think of this whole
redefinition of racism to equal racism
plus power or old definition of racism
plus power yes so it's a very clever
thing because the moment you define
racism as prejudice plus power and then
you attach the belief that black people
don't have power you set up a situation
where only white people can be racist
this is obviously very convenient if you
happen to be black especially if you
happen to be a black anti-racist
activists because it puts you in a
position where you actually can do no
wrong visa vie the issue you care about
most and it's a kind of hack that is
that is pretty ingenious there's a few
things to say about it one is that it's
completely different than the definition
of racism that characterized the civil
rights movement up until the mid 60s
in fact a philip Randolph who founded
the original march on Washington
actually warned against black people
practicing reverse racism because you
know it was clear then that the that all
kinds of racism were wrong and that
black people were just as capable of
being racist as white people are even if
the overwhelming problem throughout
American history has been anti black
racism and of course Martin Luther
King's
black black supremacy is as dangerous as
white supremacy so this is a definition
that is out of touch with the ideals
that you know supported the civil rights
movement it's also you know even if it
were true even if I accepted that racism
UCLES prejudice plus power how do you
make sense of major American cities that
are going on their fifth or sixth black
mayor in a row where the police chief is
black the district attorney is black or
almost any every person in powers is
black like Detroit or Atlanta is it
possible in in the context of a city
like that for a white person to be the
victim or an asian asian or hispanic
person to be the victim of racism so i
think it's it's it's conceptually flawed
in that it mistakes what racism is and
why racism is bad it's it's extremely
convenient for black activists and what
if they say continue what if they say
well we're not looking for black
supremacy it's just that blacks are so
held down but even if what is considered
to be old racism let's just call it
pressure even if some prejudice happens
from blacks to whites that's ok that's
ok because historically it's been on the
complete other end and they're just
evening it out and all that they can do
they can't even even it out even their
worst most prejudiced racial racist
slurs would just slightly tilt the
seesaw in their direction
but it's still predominantly in whites
what if they're like we're not headed
for blacks from similes we want blacks
as individuals to have autonomy so you
said a couple different things we want
blacks as individuals to have autonomy
I'm not sure exactly what that would
mean but as regards the the the first
thing about sort of balancing the scales
of history it kind of presupposes that
every you know act of discrimination
against a white person somehow cancels
out some previous act of discrimination
against a black person
so that in principle we could get to
some kind of place where the equation
has been equalized I mean in taken to
its logical conclusion on that view the
smart thing to do would be to enslave
white people and like cancel out slavery
I just object to the whole that whole
way of thinking I think you know not to
rehearse a cliche but an eye for an eye
makes the whole world blind the logic of
revenge is you know there's a reason in
our legal system if you get robbed
you're not allowed to rob them back or
if you get assaulted you're not allowed
to assault someone back and you know
ultimately we have to the only way to
create a sustainable civilization to not
just create a generation of new victims
that feel themselves that they have a
righteous grievance or to say it
differently you know what happens when
an Asian person that gets discriminated
against in college admissions for
example feels that okay sure in some
sense this is making up for history
because black people have experienced
more of this historically but I was born
in 1992 say and our and I kind of a
victim now that that then needs some
some kind of way of compensating for my
victimhood
down the line and then you get an
endless cycle of victims of living
people paying for the sins of dead
people and then needing new living
people to to recoup them for the
grievances that they're experiencing and
it never ends so the only way is to try
to be fair starting in the present do
you think some of part of this is that
we have to define what is extreme left
but let's just imagine oh we can use a
catch-all phrase and say the extreme
left and we pretty much know what we're
talking about do you think that those on
the extreme left radical left would say
that that they believe in an eye for an
eye makes the whole world blind because
I don't see that in their rhetoric about
punch a fascist it's as if they're
saying well fascism
is an assault on my exes on my existence
it's an existential threat therefore
because love it's not like in their eyes
a certain amount of love would have
stomped out Nazism in 1930s Germany
that's the way that they see it so
they're they want to be more physical do
you feel like my portrayal is correct do
you think that they do feel like an
eye-for-an-eye
is okay I'm not sure I understand the
question do you think that they feel
like assaulting is okay you just
advocated for a principle of
non-aggression or yeah we've been
insulted even if you've been assaulted
except in self-defense but it's not
because it right well the principle I'm
advocating for is if your group has been
so for example if you're a Jew do you
have license nowaday to say whatever you
want to a German in the year 2020 to say
horrible things about Germans as people
as a group I say no I mean I think most
most people would say no even if your
grandmother or grandfather was killed in
the Holocaust we we realized that that
kind of thing only creates a kind a
cycle of retributive abuse that never
ends so the only wise principle is not
to forget and not even necessarily to
forgive but to understand that when
people who have done horrible things are
dead you don't take it out in any way
shape or form on their children or
grandchildren or progeny in general so
that that's what I was trying to get at
if you what if those children Wells
people who came afterwards and benefited
from the system of their ancestors
I would hope they benefited from this
system of their ancestors or else it
would mean they're doing just as poorly
as their ancestors are what I would say
is that goes that goes every which way
if you want to say that white Americans
in the year 2020 have benefited from
slavery so hey that's a that's a big
claim you're making you're saying the
counterfactual where we started a
country in America that didn't rely on
slave labor is necessarily a poorer
country in the long run I'm not sure
that's true
it means we wouldn't have had to fight a
civil war which obviously made us much
poorer
you know it's so like on its face I'm
not sure it's true empirically that that
we've benefited from the fact that we
had slaves as compared to a
counterfactual where we didn't and
secondly if we did benefit if the if the
US economy is richer as a result of
slavery than it would have been
otherwise which is possible then aren't
we all benefiting from that why why
isn't it the case that you know if
you're gonna say a white immigrant that
came here in 1900 is benefiting from the
better economy from the you know the
headwind that slavery gave the US
economy why not the black immigrant that
came here at 900 aren't they also
benefiting the idea I mean I think it's
a little bit ridiculous you know again
taken to its logical conclusion am I
supposed to try to find every historical
horror from the past 10,000 years that I
somehow indirectly benefit from because
if we go down that route I think you
know what about the one about the West
Africans who sold their you know sold
Africans into slavery to the Europeans
in exchange for goods and money which
they presumably passed on to their
children are there are West Africans
today's supposed to feel like they
benefited and why not so I think this
kind of this kind of obsession with the
past and with with again visiting the
sins of the father upon the son I think
it's a horrible philosophical principle
I think it's a horrible way to think
about morality in general so let's get
psychological one
think there is this proclivity to look
into the past on its both the extreme
left and the extreme right in my
estimation but for now we're focusing on
the extreme left why do you think that
is do you think it's just you mentioned
there's a racial wealth gap not
necessarily due to discrimination but it
exists which means that people who are
on the let's just say the black who
people who are black have less and they
would like more because everybody would
like more so this is psychologically
appealing to them why do you think it's
psychologically appealing forget about
my ideas what specifically they look
sort of seeking to balance the scales of
history why is that psychologically
appealing and looking for justifications
it seems like plenty of intellectual
justifications to dislike white people
and to paint everything that they're
doing with or the majority of what they
do with a moral brush of nobility so in
a way I think I think the question is
posed backwards I think it's always been
true that groups of humans enjoy hating
other groups of humans especially people
that have more than them you know look
at any any almost any society in which
Jews have thrived over the past thousand
years has engendered enormous amounts of
hatred and anti-semitism and the reason
for is that to some degree we are
hardwired to be tribal to to have an
irrational bias towards our own people
however we define that and to hate the
out-group and so you know and to compare
how much our group has - how much of
their group has and to come up with
narratives that lay all the blame for
those disparities at another groups feet
that's the most normal you know it's
it's human and it's ugly and it's what
humans have been doing since since the
dawn of civilization so in a way it's
it's more
you know the right question is in time
and places in times where that hasn't
characterized you know inter-ethnic
interactions interracial interactions in
times of Harmony what is going right
there in a way it's our natural state to
hate and come up with reasons why you
know they stole everything from us right
right now does what's the reason for the
racial wealth gap there is no one reason
I you know the first thing I always
point out is that again the question is
a little bit posed backwards I think no
two groups with very different histories
have have have the same amount of wealth
I mean Jews and Protestants there's a
huge wealth gap between those two groups
that almost nobody is interested in to
begin with and if you are interested in
it it becomes a little suspicious like
why are you so interested in why Jews
have so much more wealth than
Protestants yet people are fascinated
and obsessed with the wealth gap between
black people and white people and they
don't see anything unhealthy about it so
that's what I just want to say to start
now if you if I grant that it's fine
to be obsessed with this wealth gap and
ask why it is and yeah certainly
historical racism is one of the reasons
they're yeah there's no way that slavery
and and the and it's aftermath you know
hundred years of discrimination that
took place in in many different forms
had no effect on the racial wealth gap
does that mean that there would be no
racial wealth gap but for those things I
find that hard to believe
only because you know there's a huge
wealth gap between Hispanics and white
people to that no one ever talks about
you know almost equally large as the one
between blacks and whites right you
mentioned that looking at the disparity
between whites and blacks paints an
incomplete picture yeah it makes it seem
like there's something strange about
there
being a you know ten to one wealth
disparity between different groups in a
multi-ethnic nation something that
requires some special explanation in
terms of slavery and Jim Crow when in
reality it's you know it's the same as
the wealth gap between Hispanics and
whites and Hispanics don't have the same
history of oppression here so either
there are huge differences in human
capital between these two groups but in
skills and in culture and all of that
plays a role to what are some ways then
for the black population to increase its
wealth maybe it could be policy changes
it could be individual choices I think
there's only one way for a person or a
group to increase its wealth in the long
run there is one common thread that you
look at any high wealth group in the
world and there's there's one way they
do it is you know education skills and
entrepreneurship there's no shortcuts
you have to develop a level of human
capital of skills that are demanded on
the market and you have to dominate at
that okay it might be you know in a
modern context it tends to be education
in college and whatnot but it can also
it can also be entrepreneurship and no
dominating certain sectors of the
economy that require very particular
skills that might not be traditional
education but you know there's there's
no shortcuts to having skills that are
in demand and that's the only
sustainable route to wealth marriage
does that have any influence yeah I mean
marriage is a yeah certainly combining
to two adults in a household that have
incomes versus one that can share the
burden of child raising is I think as
important as it seems to you know to the
average girl on the street I think you
know people in general in you know day
to day life people understand how
important marriages
and pursue it very dogged ly for that
reason but it's only when you get to
like this intellectual conversations
people are tempted to deny its
importance right right
there's a sentiment on the extreme left
in many feminist circles that marriage
is a tool of the patriarchy a tool of
oppression so yeah but most of those
people will want to get married by the
time they're 30 I think I think it's
very easy to be against marriage when
you're an 18 year old in your college
dorm who just read Judith Butler and you
know and and obviously I'm Pro I'm very
libertarian about these things so I you
know if you don't want to get married
that's that's that's great that you know
it's all about what works for you as an
individual but to say that marriage is
you know and and I would can see that in
certain cases is in certain cases
marriage is a way of trapping women
especially in other parts of the world
where it's basically compulsory but you
know in America in the typical context
where a woman is choosing whether or not
she wants to get married it's not a trap
it's a choice it's a choice that most
women want and some don't and it's it's
it's all up to the individual in my in
my estimation would you say something
that I haven't heard many I don't think
I've heard it before which is that
gentrification is salutary for black
people even though most people would say
that that's a problem in the suburbs and
low-income communities gentrification
that's a it's a white man's tool so can
you explain take me through how the heck
is it that gentrification can be
beneficial to those communities rooms
are those who are in local low-income
positions so gentrification is a is a
strange word because it just names a
natural process by which usually usually
because crime lowers in a particular
area more people want to live there and
because more people want to live there
property values go up
goes up it becomes a more desirable
place to live the concern people have is
that this pushes a low income often
black or Hispanic people who already
live there out of the neighborhood
because they can now no longer afford
rising rent so that's an empirical
question how does gentrification do that
so there was a paper that looked at the
the most populous 100 metropolitan areas
in America over a 10-year period
compared every census tract that was
gentrifying to census tracts that were
not gentrifying and follow use census
micro data on individual people to see
how many how many previous residents
that gentrification displaced and the
answer was almost none
most people when when a neighborhood is
improving and rent goes up a little bit
they pay the new level of rent because
it's worth it to them because the
neighborhood is actually getting better
so they're they're getting what they pay
for
and their the other thing the paper
found is that there you know like I
don't remember the exact number but a
huge proportion of people who owned
property who owned you know cheap
property in low-income neighborhoods are
black and their property value goes up
when gentrification happens they just
you know they become wealthier to the
tune of thousands or tens and thousands
of dollars as a result of gentrification
now what you just cited was a study and
so there are two ways of dismissing that
one way is to say well statistics don't
matter which I've heard from some of the
people on the the radical ends of the
political spectrum
another is to say that well I have lived
experience and you can't feel that from
your rational study of data points I'm
sure you've heard that this term lived
experience what's the legitimacy first
of all to the term lived experience and
second what's your rebuttal if any
I don't I mean I think it's such it's so
ridiculous it doesn't really need
rebuttal but look if there's if there's
lived experience obviously matters if
there is if we don't have good data on
something if there's something that only
you could know about because it's a you
live in a place that journalists never
come to and never study and you believe
that your experience actually gives a
better picture than is available that's
sometimes true it's not usually true
though usually we live in a you know we
live in a nation of 300 million people
and I'm not dismissing the importance of
any particular person's life story but
you know the only way to count every
life equally is actually to look at data
like to elevate your own personal
history to the point where you don't
feel you need to look at any facts or
evidence is extremely narcissistic and
implicitly counting your life as more
valuable than other people's lives it's
the opposite of a defensible moral
stance towards all of humanity
ultimately a life is a life and the only
way to actually treat it that way is to
look at data you know sometimes the
people on the social justice identity
politics type end will say that well
that's that's your opinion but me as a
black person you're black obviously but
they would say I speak on behalf they
wouldn't use these words but it's
implicit that they speak on behalf of
black people do you think were they
elected I think it's interesting to to
see how many times the folks who
implicitly speak on behalf of black
people end up being proven wrong by
black people so for example you know if
you were just reading the New York Times
and Voxx and all the people who you know
right
incendiary columns about what black
Americans you know ought to feel and
think all of them none of them wanted
Joe Biden to windy the black vote and
Joe Biden wanted overwhelmingly which
should show you how out of touch the
left-wing black commentary it is with
the median black voter in America the
meeting black vote or is is a
conservative leaning Democrat which
sounds like a paradox nowadays but is is
uh is actually more or less the case the
median black voter is Christian a little
bit conservative leaning on social
issues and votes Democrat right and I
also heard that when compared to white
men they're much more homophobic as well
that could be true I haven't seen data
on that but it would accord with you
know like the the it depends who you're
comparing it to if you're comparing two
white Democrats black Democrats and
white Democrats you're gonna find huge
issues huge differences on anything
related to social issues homophobia
feminism you're basically going to find
that black Democrats are to the right of
white Democrats on every social issue
did you used to be did you use to
self-identify with being more on the
radical end in the left spectrum yeah
when I was sixteen seventeen I
definitely would have identified I'm not
sure I really use terms like radical
left but I would have identified as
someone who posts hashtags hashtags
black lives matter on Facebook and who
identifies instinctively with that end
of the political spectrum okay and when
you were younger let's say before that
period of teenage of the teenage years
were you just a political or were you
more to the right or center yeah I was I
didn't think of myself as political but
but I liked Obama and was a Democrat
okay
what drew you to in your teenage years
to the left end and then what drew you
away
from that behavior and worldview well I
went to a conference when I was 16
called the people of color conference
which was a collection of several
hundred or maybe over a thousand high
school students from around the country
who were flown into Houston and taught
the tenets of intersectional feminism
and critical race theory and I never
heard these ideas before and they were
appealing because they put they made me
special they made they made me special
for the for the first time in my life in
a particular way by which I mean without
having to do anything at all without
having to learn a skill or become
competent at something I as a black
person suddenly became a noble victim
that was higher in status than any white
man by default and that's it that's a
really good feeling frankly it's it does
feel a little bit like cheating but at
the same time it it makes a person feel
like you are you have this suddenly have
this standing in in a community of
friends where you can call people out
and you know you've you just inherit
this kind of status as a result of your
victimhood that makes you cool and
special so yeah all of you all of that
was attractive to me at age 16 then what
happened I thought about it more and
talk to people and read books and listen
to podcasts and realized that many of
the most of the ideas that I had learned
were attractive because they cuz they
made me feel selfishly good not because
they were true or ethically defensible
or helped combat racism in any real way
so yeah I mean there was no aha moment
but it was just a gradual series of
running into
you know facts and arguments that
persuaded me that that I was wrong now
some of these people met many people on
both extremes would not want to hear
differing opinions or when they do
they'd become more adamant in their
stance how is that you we're different
it seems like yours is predicated on
self analysis almost like psychoanalysis
is to hear my various motivations like
maybe I do believe this for reasons that
afford me status when I I don't
particularly don't particularly deserve
it and it feels great well why were you
different than the other people who are
on these extreme ends I'm not sure I was
so different I think like everyone I
struggle with an attachment to the
police that I have that the current you
know version of me has and a tendency to
defend them in the face of evidence let
me put it a different way imagine
someone a mentor you could speak to your
18 year old self who is to use a word
that I don't particularly like
indoctrinated in the ideology of the
extreme left
what would you say it's step one read
listen to this podcast step to read this
book what would your plan look like I
guess my plan would look like more or
less what I did which was all of that
that you mentioned I think I I've
definitely always been a little probably
more than average concerned with whether
a proposition is really true I think
I've always been a little more concerned
than average than the average person
with logical coherence like if you say
two things and they contradict each
other I think I have the kind of mind
that is more concerned with that they
don't contradict contradict each other
then the typical person I think that
probably contributes to to you know
being able to change my mind if I can
really if I can if it can really be
shown that two things I
think are in contradiction it makes me
very very uncomfortable and it makes me
want to get my beliefs in order and I
think you know everyone is like that to
some degree but it's a you know there's
a spectrum there are people that are
really more okay with having beliefs
that are in tension and people that can
almost can't have any beliefs that are
in tension so I'm I'm more towards one
end of that scale and I think that's
probably why that probably contributes
to why I have been able to change my
mind over the course in my life but I
don't mean to paint myself as
particularly special I think you know
I'm within the normal range on all of
those kind of cognitive or personality
traits right well I know some people who
I would imagine share the same level of
cognitive dissonance as you but they
don't see this maybe they don't see what
you see as a contradiction as a
contradiction so did you develop that by
what did you just listen to people who
was a Joe Rogan was it Peterson let's
get it to a bit of specific so that's
someone who is listening who maybe is
being attracted and they really they're
self-aware enough to know that they're
being attracted to to one of the
extremes what should they do to temper
it they probably don't want to temper it
right if they're really attracted to it
but yeah in terms of stuff I listen to
when I was 18 yeah I'd listen to Joe
Rogan a little bit I listen to Sam
Harris's podcast I I had conversations
with people like in person about
political issues who disagreed with me
who were coming from a more right
leaning perspective and okay now that's
that's interesting because most of these
people most people and our generation
don't have conversations in person they
tend to have it online
Facebook and Twitter and
I don't think that's particularly
salutary there's something about
in-person dialogue that's as important
do you think that part of this political
divisive 'no so we're seeing is is
driven by our lack of in-person contact
I'm not gonna say social media in
general because that's to make no yeah I
think it's definitely much harder to
have a good conversation with someone
online people online don't seem like
full 3d people they seem like
caricatures and it's very easy to hate a
caricature it's much harder to hate a
person face to face I'm wondering right
now because I've seen the political
device in business just has been insane
since I started the documentary and then
it's increased drastically in the past
few months and now I'm wondering is that
related to the fact that we're in
quarantine oh we can't speak face to
face with one another I mean I wouldn't
be surprised I wouldn't be surprised if
that's a part of this story if that's a
part of the story I think people are
watching too much news they're looking
at their news feeds more than they
normally would they're not distracted by
going to work every day to the same
degree that they are that they used to
be and all of that provides more you
know opportunities to become extremely
angry about the thing that you just saw
on your newsfeed that seems horrible so
yeah there's just more potential to
become angry right now because of
lockdown let's take a look at this white
supremacy triangle that I was
referencing earlier for the people who
are listening I will direct you to the
URL in the description and for people
watching it's on screen right now it's
about white supremacy what's overt and
what's not overt racism so tell me what
do you agree with on this what do you
disagree with yeah so everything on the
overt white supremacy list is I agree is
racist that should go without saying
so okay nice murder sorry there's one
that says we're all human okay that's
right just go on to human family now
that's seen as colorblind racism what do
you think I mean I think we are a human
family like okay you and I you you look
like your ancestors are from the Indian
subcontinent is that right that's racist
you can't believe you seven white
supremacists eight yeah
so I am i route my parents are from
Trinidad I was born in Trinidad Ville
okay so if it's not okay to say that
we're just one human family what does
that mean for you and me in this
conversation does that mean that I'm
supposed to believe that there is some
deep important barrier between us
as people because you are of one race
and I'm of a different one is that what
I'm actually supposed to believe because
if it's if I'm not supposed to say but
we're just one human family what am I
supposed to say in place of that
statement
it seems very at odds with what should
be the goal which is for our society to
condemn racism precisely because we
understand that we are one human family
that's supposed to be the reason racism
is bad to begin with so it's
inconsistent to say on the one hand that
you're an anti-racist and on the other
that we shouldn't believe we're one
human family because that's precisely
the moral grounding of anti racism or at
least it should be what about some of
what else is on there what do you
particularly disagree with on the
opposite racism or non overt racism side
so claiming reverse racism
again are you really gonna say that
Martin Luther King and a Phillip
Randolph were wrong to worry about
reverse racism that their picture of
racism was naive and and you because you
know you you read some Abram candy have
a have a more full and accurate picture
of racism than they did I think it's
ridiculous I think of course reverse
racism is possible I mean what do you
call it when what would you call it it's
a black person murdered a white person
because they're white well what what
language conceptually would you have to
condemn that with if not racism no just
to interject Coleman one of my issues
with this is that they'll say well
that's not racism that's prejudice but
to me it's like fine you can call it
Abudu yeah it didn't call whatever you
like is ABBA do okay is prejudice okay
then all right hey to kill my person for
being white who cares if you're saying
it's not racism I don't care the label
that's the whole structuralist Clinton
doesn't matter the specific enunciation
of the word it matters its relationship
to other words what it means right no
you're completely right it's a it's this
way of semantically wiggling out of the
problem without actually saying anything
of substance it's like saying well
there's a difference between killing and
murder when white people do it it's
murder
when black people do it it's just
killing it's like okay but killing is
just as bad right
ultimately we you know you can't let
people wiggle out of hard conversations
because you know with semantic tricks
like that hating someone on account of
the color of their skin or their
presumed ancestry is evil if that's not
true nothing is true and it has to be as
true regardless of the person being
hated let's look at a couple more one is
expecting people of color to teach white
people
I haven't I'm not white but I've
experienced something I came to that
where I was asking what what's the how
is this a cultural appropriation as an
example they like oh if you don't know
what culture you need to look that up on
your own they won't talk with you about
that I'll cite you to other sources
someone else recently there's a viral
video of someone who's said someone
who's bouncing a brown baby on his lap
and some colleague of his said that was
racist he's like how is that racist I'm
just holding my colleagues child then
he's like if you don't know why that's
racist you need to read a book excuse me
I'm a social justice patronizing not
being me
I want to make how to be a better white
person I would like to know before this
meeting adjourns as if that person's not
supposed to tell you the person of color
is never supposed to teach so what do
you think of that expecting people of
color to teach white people I think
again this is a very clever thing I
think frankly I think a lot of social
justice people are racial justice
warriors whatever you know whatever you
want to call people a lot of them are
insecure when they call someone out
because it actually like
it's a rather bold thing to do to call
someone out as a racist publicly it
takes a little bit of guts and you're
putting your own reputation on the line
and potentially embarrassing yourself so
when you call someone a racist or sexist
publicly your heart is beating a little
bit and if they challenge you and defend
themselves and their defense actually
kind of makes sense now you're in a
position where you stand to lose a lot
of faiths so I think what people end up
doing in that position sometimes is
saying well it's not my job to teach you
why you're wrong
and that is a very powerful tactic
because it means you don't have to
respond to their defenses of themselves
you can just fall back on that line and
it can seem to plug the holes in your
otherwise weak argument so I think
that's just a function of insecurity on
the part of of people making the
argument if you if you had if you had a
great argument for why someone is being
racist or sexist
you wouldn't just keep it in your back
pocket and say it's not my job to teach
you you would say it it sounds like it's
both insecurity and a lack of an actual
argument yeah okay what about this last
one which says it's not the last one
there's plenty on here and I recommend
anyone who's watching this and what
we're listening to look at the triangle
not believing the experiences of people
of color is considered to be covert
white supremacy not believing the
experiences of people of color is
considered to be an element of covert
white supremacy so I had to believe
Jesse Smollett I you know so like here's
the thing is is there is this unwritten
part of the far-left belief system which
says that people of color are like
inhumanly perfect and all
and that's it's really out of touch
because quote-unquote people of color
lied just as much as white people do and
it's to recognize a person in their
humanity in their full team and this is
to recognize both their good traits and
their flaws so it seems crazy to me to
say that you have to you have to believe
someone because their skin color is a
particular way and I was thinking what
would they say they may say well we
don't mean just believe us no matter
what we just mean don't dismiss us and
the response that I would have would be
well I I can listen but I can still put
up a defense or pose a counter-argument
I'm am I not allowed to do that right
yeah then it gets to so like it's one of
those motte-and-bailey style arguments
where if you press them on and they'll
say well all we're saying is don't
dismiss us out of racism and it's like
okay who would disagree with that but
then the next breath are saying yeah
believe us no matter what
the second Jessie smell that happens
anyone who raised questions about at the
beginning was considered a racist so
when push comes to shove the reason it
says not believing experiences of POC is
because that's what they mean what they
say at least half the time or enough of
the time for the strongest or the the
the sharpest version of their belief to
be worth criticizing have you been
called any names from the people on the
far right such as Uncle Tom on the far
right sorry
far left sure yeah all of the all of the
yeah okay that you let's go through it
and and why and can you give me a cup of
pick one of them pick one of the
examples and then give me some context
I'm curious to know what happened why
they said that I mean it's obvious to
some degree but for the listeners
yeah I mean I don't think it's such an
interesting topic of conversation to go
through all the you know things people
have called me just because I don't like
dwelling on any personal sense of
victimhood but yes you know Uncle Tom
and [ __ ] are probably the the the most
common ones and it's just the the notion
that you're a traitor to your race that
society is a it's essentially a war
between people between races between
different groups and you don't want
anyone from your group telling the enemy
your battle plans that's like the
implicit view of someone who calls a
black person and Uncle Tom or COO
because I don't think society is a war I
think people are individuals I think I'm
not going to be I'm not gonna be scared
into saying or thinking what you want me
to think because your definition of
blackness entails a particular politics
right same definition of whiteness right
well they know whiteness doesn't really
entail a particular politics you know
white people never get criticized for
being traitors really drag race right
right okay do you think there exists
institutional racism if so what is it
and if not why not
so that that phrase institutional racism
comes from a book written in 1967 called
black power and the examples given in
that book were discriminatory lending
real estate agents steering black people
to one neighborhood versus another the
examples that were given were what I
would just call subtle racial bias by
individuals so yeah I think that exists
there's no question that exists I think
it exists less than it has
at any point in the past 50 years but
yeah I think racial bias exists I don't
know what people mean when they say
institutional yeah and it's not because
I haven't read all any of the right
books of the right studies I've read all
of it
I just don't think people are being very
precise with their lamb I see something
similar when it comes to the word system
or systemic part of the problem that I
had with the documentary is with the
document produced in a documentary just
for the people listening on the topic
off when does the left go too far and so
I've had to familiarize myself plenty
with the literature and it's not as if
there is any consensus or clarity to
these terminologies like systemic racism
institutional racism no I mean the the
sometimes when people say with systemic
is systemic racism means that a system
can be racist without any individual in
the system being racist okay that's
again this is let's let's think about
this if the prison system is racist the
pipeline starts with a police officer
then would go to a prosecutor then we go
to a judge and juries you're telling me
if every individual in that pipeline is
completely non racist like comically
impossibly colorblind still somehow the
system can be racist without there being
overtly racist laws I'm kind of confused
again I understand that racism exists to
not say I'm not saying it doesn't I'm
saying the opposite I'm saying racial
bias in the minds of individuals
definitely exists and that's a tough
thing to ameliorate and it's it's
usually more subtle than the caricature
of a KKK member but what do we gain by
saying it's institutional I'm not sure I
I think it's a very imprecise way of
speaking and when someone asked me if I
think institutional racism exists I feel
like I'm just
being asked to pass a litmus test of
whether I'm a good person right its
imprecise though it's purposeful they
use that language purpose with imprecise
right
what you know anyway that's that's what
I explained this lie of omission you
mentioned about the narrative that black
people diet that at the hands of cops
when there are also white people who die
at the hands of cops
such as Tinie Tempah you mentioned it as
a lie of omission and I'm curious to
know what you meant by that I'm curious
for you to expound sure I think you know
ever since Trayvon Martin was killed by
George Zimmerman in 2012 many Americans
have you know every few months seen in
their news feed either story or a video
which involved the black person being
killed by a white cop I don't think you
know I think it would be pointless for
me to even you've been saying the names
of the examples because everyone knows
them what they haven't seen are the many
more examples of white people getting
killed in the same situations people
people know the name Michael Brown but
they don't know the name Daniel Elrod
who was a white guy who got killed in
almost identical circumstances just a
few months later you know they know they
know Freddie gray and Alton Stirling but
they don't know Dillon Noble or Daniel
shaver you know these are all white
people who got killed unarmed by the
cops
no one knows their names at all I don't
mean that literally some people do know
their names but you know if you just
look at the Google searches for Michael
Brown versus Daniel Elrod by I mean my
god it's the orders of magnitude more
interest in one rather than the other
and most people don't care enough to do
research and see well actually how many
white people versus black people get
killed by the cops
so the lie of omission is that this kind
of thing happens mainly or
overwhelmingly to black people it's just
not true as for the recent example of
sorry is there a part of of the people
on the far left who want it to be the
case that black people are killed
disproportionately at the hands of cops
compared to white people and that's one
of the reasons why we know about this
narrative rather than the other data
points the news might cover both equally
I don't think they do but let's imagine
they do then there's also the sharing of
the news so what gets more popularized
okay so I'm trying to work backwards why
is it that I I also don't know how much
until I research this I didn't know how
much how many white people died but then
I thought it was just only black or my
majorly black people died at the hands
of cops in the so desire so why why is
that is it just is it the people who are
writing the news who are biased is the
people who are sharing it on Facebook
who are biased is that we want to
believe it for some reason what's going
I think I think that Americans are many
Americans especially on the left grow up
seeing videos as I did of white
policemen hosing and siccing the dogs on
peaceful black protesters in the 1960s
and that image is seared into the
American subconscious so that when we
see something like it it angers us much
more than if we see a white person doing
it to a white person or even a black
person doing it to a black person much
less a black person doing it to a white
person so we fail to recognize when we
enter a new era have you heard of
Simpsons paradox what's that it's that
some data points are more likely like
the correlation between good-looking
people being arrogant and disrespectful
we
well the more good-looking you are the
more likely we're to be rude but what's
actually going on is rude ugly people
you don't pay attention to because
they're ugly already so you just they're
not even a part of your mind then the
more good-looking someone is the more
you're willing to give them some leeway
and interact with them and therefore the
best looking person can have the status
of being rude and then you think there's
a correlation when there's actually none
and I'm wondering like you said there's
a line from Tony Robbins so a
self-development guru said that imagine
you're scarred then a cat hair if you
just touch that point on your hand it
will hurt you but you can take a coal on
your other hand where there's no scar
and you won't feel anything so now I'm
wondering if that is is akin to the is
if that leads to the Simpsons paradox
when it comes to black people being
killed by the cops how would that work
with with black people okay well you
don't care too much when it's a white
person it just doesn't get spread
because you don't notice it and then so
you see the correlation with black
people when cops yeah that's essentially
what I'm describing it's a it's a I
think of it more as coverage bias which
is just that like the the set of events
you're paying attention to are already
narrowed down to 5% of the total cases
saying and you treat that as if it's the
whole universe of cases so yeah so you
know people people know the two dozen
names of high-profile police killings of
black people over the past eight years
or so there probably been something like
8,000 Americans killed by cops in the
past eight years and the largest share
of those have been white and most people
couldn't name a single one right so you
know it's it's it's it's just the fact
that things would be very different if
the national media reported every
instance of an unarmed person killed by
the cops equally and even then as you
say you'd have to contend with
fact that people are much more likely to
share it if there's a racism angle the
clear racism angle what do you think of
this defunding police narrative I think
I'm very interested in police reform and
how we can make cops behave better and
more reliably avoid instances of police
brutality and unjustified killings and
be accountable
yeah and and and be held accountable
when they do misbehave we have a the
status quo is is woefully inadequate
that said I'm very curious to see and
haven't seen a shred of evidence that
suggests that defunding will help that
often it's the case that cops are
overworked understaffed need more
training all of those things on their
face might require more funding not less
mm-hmm I think I was gonna say sounds
similar to teachers understaffed
underpaid yes like before yes it's not a
great idea right if we wanted to improve
public education with the first idea be
to defund teachers often improving a
system requires putting more funding
into it not less so I think you know the
the black lives matter movement it has a
way of hitting on a thing that is a real
issue and then just precisely going to
the thing that won't solve it which is
really it seems almost like a feature
rather than a bug you know it's the
thing that sounds radical over the thing
that might actually work
mm-hmm what do you see as some of the
most exigent problems of the day the
most important problems so for example
to the black lives matter people they
may see racism as the number one issue
we need to fix for some others its
climate change someone's it's nuclear
disarmament
or China if you're trauma or
nanotechnology or rogue a GI artificial
general intelligence what do you see I
think I'm you know I don't study eggs
assent existential risk very closely but
my impression is that nuclear war should
always be somewhere near the top of our
list climate change presents seems to
present to me a real challenge long-term
even if it's not even if it's not quite
the apocalyptic scenario that you might
suppose if you're only looking at the
most alarmist material on it
artificial intelligence I don't have an
opinion on I've paid attention to the
people who are worrying about it and
frankly I just come away thinking I see
smart arguments on both sides of the
issue saying that you know it's the it's
the thing that's gonna destroy us and
telling us to calm down I don't have an
opinion on that
yeah I mean that that's that's about all
I can say so common for me one of the
reasons why I pick on the extreme left
or both even the extreme right to some
degree is that I see it as a distraction
from our true problems like some of the
ones I listed so yeah a distraction is a
great word for it and alternatively I
also see it as a repetition of something
that's happened in the 1900s and I don't
see it as leading to anywhere good what
are your reasons for focusing on the
dismantling of the ideas of the far
right of sorry far left or far right
well I mean it's good that you pose it
that way because I'm very opposed to the
ideas on the far right I just think that
you know it it hardly needs to be I
hardly need to add my voice to
it's so obvious that Nazism is wrong
like no one is no one who is a halfway
decent person is tempted to defend those
ideas and despite the fact that Trump is
president and at minimum doesn't make a
point of distancing himself from the far
right or it doesn't doesn't as much as
one would want him to I think that style
of politics is on the way out I think
Trump is much is not the sign of things
to come but is like the the dinettes of
sorry the end of an era yeah I think so
I think he's fairly unpopular I'm not
gonna say that I don't know he could win
another term he is the incumbent
advantage and whatnot but I think the
kind of coalition that Obama assembled
is going to point the direction for the
country in the long term more than the
coalition that Trump assembled so I'm
not worried long term about the
resurgence of Nazism and white supremacy
in the United States I mean show me a
single major institution in America
whose problem is is whose real problem
is like white racism like the colleges
the media institutions I'm sorry is it
you know I can if you can show me one I
can show you 10 where the problem is
that they're overrun by far-left ideas
so that's the direction things are
pointing in the long run and that's why
I'm more worried about it and that's why
I don't spend so much time telling
people that white supremacy and racism
and Nazism are wrong because my god if
you if you don't know that by now then
you're hopeless
so so what I'm worried about is an
increase in a set of very fashionable
ideas about what it means to make
progress as a country that ultimately
involves creating a huge set of
government policies designed to equalize
everything by group so that black people
are 13% of the population and 13% of
every slice of reality you could
possibly think of from income to wealth
to occupations to and that's the kind of
world that someone like Abram Kennedy
wants to see explicitly and to the
extent that far-left ideas become more
popular that goal becomes more and more
a reality and it's a reality that
doesn't care about individual people at
all it's a reality that despite claiming
to be for social justice is actually
deeply unjust in the sense that it
doesn't care at all what costs it
imposed imposes on individuals in order
to get to its imagined utopia and so yes
I worry about that I worry about the
fact that you know people who believe in
this try to shut down any criticisms of
them and try to shut down free speech
and I you know I think you study the
history of revolutions all around the
world and you see people make the same
mistakes over and over again all of
these amazing sounding ideas that once
they overthrow the regime end up
becoming just as tyrannical and and so
that's what I worry about and that's why
I criticize you know when I was filming
for better left unsaid I had I own
pretty much just talked to white people
and then I was criticized for that but
it's not as if Coleman I didn't reach
out like
we men I reached out to many people who
weren't white and many people who just
robbed the far left end of the spectrum
and just got nothing no responses this
is a question for me to answer but I'm
I'm posing it to you why do you think
that is are most of the people who are
commenting against the far left are they
in fact white or or are they just not
willing to speak up because like
yourself they're then accused of being
Uncle Tom's and Coons or did I just get
unlucky I don't know I would have to
know more of the circumstances of how
you reached out to them but in general I
share the experience of often just you
know the often it's not that the
far-left rebuts arguments against their
ideas well so much as it just ignores
them for example black conservatives
like Thomas Sowell it's not so much that
there have been that he's been dogged
piled by people on the Left he's mainly
been ignored so yeah I think it's
unpleasant to interact with people who
strongly disagree with you that's also
true on the right so a lot of people on
the right will avoid people on the left
but it is asymmetric and in fact I
remember a study that was done of
journalists on Twitter which found that
journalists on the Left were much less
likely to follow journalists on the
right than vice-versa right when
journalists were much more likely to
follow their their counterparts on the
Left that's also anecdotally true and I
think it does come down to a kind of
difference between the right and the
left the right is much more concerned
about the less ideas then the left is
with the rights in a way the left I
think is more likely to pretend that
folks on when we're saying the left when
you're saying the word at the left do
you mean the far left or do you mean the
left in general in this case I mean both
you know I'm just I'm basing that off of
this Twitter study and off of
observation but there's an asymmetric
attention that is paid between the sides
where the right pays more attention to
what folks on the Left are saying and
writing than the vice-versa
one of my colleagues wanted to know he
said he said that's just quoting I would
love to know what what Coleman wants
from white people in all seriousness for
example you have all these social
justice activists saying that they want
white people to examine their own racism
challenge their beliefs give money to
black people but what does Coleman want
if anything I would never say this comes
down to a very big difference between
how I think I would never ask white
people on mass to do anything is
ridiculous ask I would never ask any
group of people racially to to do
anything I mean be an individual have
the courage of your convictions
understand that nobody is better or
worse than you and nobody could demand
that you do or believe something on
account of your race
that's ridiculous it's an insult to your
dignity regardless of what your race is
so make up your own mind to consider
their arguments educate yourself and do
what seems to be the right thing based
on what you believe don't be bullied
that's the same advice I would give to
anyone
great advice another viewer and this
time said that Coleman doesn't talk much
about the philosophy behind the current
woke autumn cult movement I'd be
interested in knowing what he thinks
about that especially regarding Lindsey
and [ __ ] Rose James Lindsay and Helen
Ross ensure you your wick being of a
philosophical background you're aware of
the grievant studies so what do you
think of it oh okay so that's what they
mean yeah so there are a guess a few
different strands of philosophy that
make up the academic foundation of the
local movement one would be critical
race theory
so basically the tenets of critical race
theory that are important are that you
know it is kind of the racism equals
prejudice plus power that's ultimately
where it comes from the idea that any
appeal to common humanity or to
universal principles like reason is
actually just white supremacy in
disguise the analogy I sometimes think
of is you know when you're a kid and you
first learned the concept of an accent
like a vocal accent you think that only
other people have accents and you just
speak right you have this kind of
neutral voice but then you get to a
certain age and you realize well
actually everyone has an accent my
definition you have an accent if you're
speaking and there is no there's no
center of gravity from which everything
else is an accent there's no view from
nowhere so what the critical race Theory
is want to say is that's what everything
is like that's what reason is like there
is no place to stand from from which to
criticize other people's perspectives as
irrational or or wrong because
ultimately everything just comes from a
particular point of view and there's no
there's no way to decide between
different narratives you just have to
acknowledge that you know a white
narrative is coming from a white person
a black narrative is coming from black
people and in the end is just about
power right marionette and then and
therein lies the contradiction because
the first claim which is that there it
there are no claims that are to be held
as truthful contradicts the one claim
which is well therefore power yeah yeah
that's ultimately there's a great book
by the philosopher Thomas Nagel which is
called the last word which I recommend
people read and it
it is it argues that all of these
philosophies are self contradictory
because they claim to be the very meta
narratives that they define out of
existence screen if you're gonna say
that there is no universal truth that
there is no universal standard to appeal
to to decide whether a claim is true or
a claim is morally correct if you're if
you're gonna say that that kind of thing
is impossible there are only competing
narratives that are all subjective and
in the end you just have to sort of pick
one and try to attain power with it you
run into the problem that the whole
belief system you just exposed was
claiming to be the very meta narrative
that it's claimed it just claiming
doesn't exist it's kind of like saying a
hundred percent of statistics are false
because if it's not sentence is true
that it's false and if it's false then
it's true there's also another
contradiction coming from my field
physics in that well if they say that
the field of physics is racist because
they exclude minorities certain
minorities you can't make that claim
unless you already buy in to the
supposition that physics is based on an
ontology of truth that there's something
objective about the world because of
physics was just investigating what
subjective let's say it's just white
people run amok what the heck do you
care if these white people who are
pursuing their own Eurocentric interests
exclude black people do you black people
want to be involved in what in spreading
white Eurocentrism okay that's just my
small rent let's get into the pros and
cons of the black lives matter movement
why don't you steal man the movement
give a best-case scenario this comes
from a viewer so I'm reading it give a
best-case scenario and and a worst-case
scenario thoughts on how this will play
out over the next year best-case
scenario is that black lives matter puts
out a lot of a lot of bad proposals for
how to fix the problem of police
violence as almost a first move in a
negotiation but by the end of the
process
we settle on passing laws that are
actually very reasonable and we don't do
fun the police I mean leave it's already
happened in New York but police in
general don't get defunded they get
reformed or dismantled and replaced in
positive ways and none of the other
demands of black lives matter to you
know teach critical race theory to
kindergarteners say none of that stuff
happens all that comes out of it is just
a heightened concern about police
brutality this also comes from a viewer
we're just wrapping up a couple more
questions interested how do you spend
your time debating current issues with
your friends and family versus
discussing them in public ways like
what's the difference and do you even
discuss it with your friends and family
yes I do discuss it with my friends and
family so the questions how do I spend
my time like what quite the question was
two-part it's first of all I'm gonna
reiterate that I'm gonna rephrase the
question sure what's the difference
between you discussing it with your
family and friends versus how you
discuss it in public well I think partly
you tailor how you talk about things
based on who you're talking to and what
you know they respond to and what they
want to talk about I think a lot of
people I end up talking to in context
like this are people that make a living
of thinking and talking about political
or cultural issues and as a result they
think and talk in a in a way that is
different from how like my average
friend would think and talk about it so
ultimately I don't I don't really speak
differently it's just that if I know if
I know someone and I know someone's
history and I've been friends with you
for five years you know
it's possible that I can appeal to
stories that we both experienced as
arguments where I wouldn't be able to do
that you find that those conversations
are harder or harsher because you know
the people have you lost friends because
of it or family members yeah I haven't
lost any good friends because of
politics I've lost acquaintances that I
frankly don't really lament losing so
much yeah in a way they're harder in a
way they can be easier because you're
already starting from the premise that
with friends it can be easier because
you're starting from the premise that
you like each other you became friends
for a reason in the first place so
there's a lot of just like love there to
begin with with family can be harder
because you know there's a reason
there's the cliche of talking about
politics at Thanksgiving dinner and why
that's a bad idea someone else wrote so
what do you think of someone who let's
say is white wearing dreadlocks using
black cents twerking alright those
examples of cultural appropriation what
do you think of the concept of cultural
appropriation in general I think it's
about how you do it you know I'm not
going to pretend that in a country of
300 million people that every time a
white person has put on dreads that it's
that I know that that is a symbol of
disrespect and appropriation I don't
know like no intention manners yeah of
course intention matters I mean well you
can say of course but keep in mind
people on the far left cuz that's true
no that's true yes some people don't
think the intention intention matters
but matters a modicum compared to the
impact yeah I think it's it's one thing
to steal something from a subculture it
give that subculture no credit pass it
off as if you've invented it and then
make millions off it I do find something
icky about that
so if there's truth to the idea of
cultural appropriation it's that that
has happened and that people should be
on their guard for that not to happen
mm-hmm
however the idea that black people own
the concept of wearing dreads for all
time there is us yeah and tonight I just
don't see where a what is the
justification for that
B why do we why are we so possessive
with our culture it's again it smacks of
insecurity that you don't want to share
a hairstyle the only the only way and
yeah maybe that insecurity comes from
the history of white supremacy but I
think we should recognize that that's
what it is there's also the counterclaim
which is there's an essentialist claim
from the far left about cultural
appropriation even though they don't
like essentialism saying that because
I'm black this is my culture so you can
identify with your culture by being of a
race that's the same as nationalism in
my eyes additionally there's there's
another counterclaim which is let's say
I brought this up to Eric Weinstein
actually that someone like Eminem or
someone who just popularize it something
that is traditionally black you can see
that as a slight and you can take it you
can interpret it like that but at the
same time that person has now opened the
doors to the marketing towards now
there's now rap is is loved by the
scrawny white kids even black they love
black rappers because of Eminem so in a
sense cultural appropriation is
deleterious and it's not welcomed but at
the same time it does open the door for
it to be consumed by more people
whatever the phenomenon is whether it's
dreadlocks or whether it's rap so I see
it from both angles
yeah I'm trying to with this whole
documentary I'm trying to delineate the
difference between the reasonable left
maybe you would think of that as Harris
or even Eric Weinstein as I mentioned or
Pinker and unreasonable left would you
called the far left what do you see as
that line what are the beliefs that once
you hold them now your far left now
you're unreasonable if you believe that
we should try to balance the scales of
historical and justice by imposing costs
on people who had nothing to do with the
original injustice
I think that's unreasonable if you think
that people only have a right to speak
about issues that they have personally
experienced I think that's unreasonable
I'll rephrase it once more in other
words when does the Left go too far to
use the subtitle of the film so you
mentioned too is there one more knot
that occurs to me right now what about
when the right goes too far
when does the right to go too far
obviously there's a reasonable right at
least I think so and there's a
reasonable F what they have mixed it
unreasonable for the right any kind of
coercion that stops people from living
how they want to live if they're not
harming anyone else opposing gay
marriage is when the right goes too far
because to gay people who want to get
married aren't hurting anyone any kind
of laws that restrict victimless
behavior what do you mean I would say
criminalizing marijuana is when the
right right goes too far
as well the attempt to socially control
behavior that is seen as immoral but
doesn't actually impose a cost on others
is where the right tends to go too far
as well as the obvious you know anti
black racism sexism national anthem Oh
nationalism in particular
ethno-nationalism okay now since we have
time what where do you defer with Sam on
the moral landscape I don't I think it's
a it's a brilliant book it's a brilliant
attempt to carve out a way of thinking
about right and wrong in a world where
we don't have a good reason to believe
in God a way of you know preserving our
attempt to make the world a better place
without lapsing into cultural relativism
you know the tendency to say well
however however you want to build the
society is equally good we have no right
to judge so I think it does a great job
of avoiding that of combating that
instinct on the left and combating the
instinct on on the right to say that
without God there's no such thing as
right and wrong okay so you're of the
type that believes that values can be
derived from the facts yes you know it's
Daniel Dennett said if if we can't get
values from a full account of reality
and where could we possibly get them
from well it depends on what the full
account of reality means doesn't
incorporate something like a
transcendence which is encapsulated in
some religions as god no sam says that
the most egregious suffering for all
conscious beings is what is considered
to be bad but that in and of itself is
not a fact
it's still a I see it still has a value
judgment so can you explain to me
because you said that you agree how is
that not a value judgment how is that
affect this is a little bit like
distinguishing between racism and
Prejudice before it's semantics whatever
you want to call it a fact or you know a
squib it is highly plausible that it's
it's a very deeply compelling intuition
that the worst possible suffering for
everyone is bad well and moving in the
opposite direction is good and it gets
you where you need to go in terms of
building some kind of just just at being
able to have a conversation about right
and wrong from from the point of view of
moral philosophy right very right well
you said it's an intuition the fact that
it's an intuition doesn't make much of a
difference because there are plenty of
people who can have other intuitions
such as serial killers who say are
people who have been tortured when they
were younger who just want to promulgate
evil and suffering instead and say that
that well that's great that's what I'm
moving towards or and even if it's an
intuition that we all hold it doesn't
matter that that says nothing about
whether it should be done because we
could have evolved differently I'm not
sure I understand what you're saying so
you're saying the fact that a serial
killer could have a different intuition
might have a different intuition right
you you officiates any attempt to make
like a moral an objectively true moral
system what I'm saying is that you said
it it's akin to calling racism prejudice
or the interchange between those two
words that is just
pedantic to co-op to argue about the
semantics but I don't think it is in
this case I think that when one says
that there's that is it's we should move
away from the total suffering of all
people I still see that as a value
judgment and that's not as if that's
self-evident from from objective fact I
still see it as a value judgment you're
like well that value judgment is
predicated in intuition and therefore
it's correct at least that's what I
understood from what you said and I was
taking exception to that so ultimately
yeah you know any any any feel of any
any philosophical argument hits
philosophical bedrock at some point you
hit a belief that needs that you need
not justify with further arguments
because or else you would have an
infinite regress this would be this is
true with mathematics with anything you
just hit a stopping point where yeah you
know one plus one is two if you ask me
why I actually can't justify it with
further arguments it's just a brute
intuition and if you don't have it then
there's actually no way of settling
between opposing intuitions at that
level right so to me it is
self-evidently true that the worst
possible suffering forever for everyone
is bad and any movement away from it is
good that's as bedrock as one plus one
equals two so to argue about whether
it's a fact or a value judgment is is I
think irrelevant it's just like
self-evidently compelling okay call me
we'll talk about that some other time
why don't you tell the audience what
you're working on next and where they
can find out more about you um they can
find out more about me at my Twitter at
cold ex-man or my website Coleman Hughes
org and you can see my writing some my
older essays that colette and my newer
pieces at city journal thank you so much
have a
thanks for having me